nous sommes le premier parti de France
en termes de militants je l'ai dit c'est
vous vous êtes nous sommes le premier
parti de France et de très loin en
termes d'élus nous avons nous des
racines nous avons des bases nous avons
ces territoires nous avons des militants
nous partageons des valeurs nous
démontrons au quotidien qu'on sait gérer
des territoires qu'on n'est pas coupé
des réalités que vivent les Français
auxquels ils sont confrontés au
quotidien dans un moment de grande
épreuve de grande difficulté et bien oui
ces atouts ils sont là et personne ne
pourra les effacer et ils sont le socle
il constitue les fondations de cette
maison que je veux demain reconstruire
nous sommes les républicains
et nous voulons redresser les
républicains parce que les républicains
c'est la France c'est la France grande
fier forte celle du général de Gaulle
celle dont on sait tellement écarté
alors notre maison a été abîmée la
toiture a peut-être été emportée par la
tempête mais les murs porteurs sont là
les fondations sont là et c'est nous qui
devons reconstruire c'est cette tâche
qui m'attend pas simplement moi une
équipe
qui m'entourent qui incarne qui
représente la diversité des des
sensibilités